the support for Independence has barely
moved on than 10 years since you've had
the referendum what you mean is that the
last poll showed it at 52% which is a
very large sex on the population Fraser
you know if I had had a poll when we
started the independence campaign proper
in 2012 the the Edinburgh agreement that
showed independent support at 52% as
opposed to the poll showing it at 28%
which what was then I would have given
my it for that I mean you got more than
half a population despite everything
you've mentioned who think independ
that's a good idea what a fantastic
basee on which to to pursue the the
summit of of Scottish so it's still
going to happen in your lifetime is it
oh yeah I mean you know politicians
could make a real muck of things you
know they they can they can rough Hue
things how they will but what really
matters is the underlying base of
support for Scottish independence that's
that's what's the the Bedrock you'll get
politicians at some point who will
organize an Affairs in such a way as to
take that obvious political advantage
and bring it to a reality